حول هذا الموضوع معنا هنا في الاستوديو
العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك عميد الياس حنا كيف
يمكن تقييم هذا التقدم الذي تتحدث
اوكرانيا عن احرازه في باخمت
الهجوم سيكون بمكان ما وخارق وكبير وحشد
وهذا ليس مؤكد قد يكون الهجوم على عده
جبهات تراكميه
قطعه قطعه وبالتالي يحققون هذا الامر فاذا
هذا هو وضع مخمود يتحدث الطرف الاوكراني
عن تقدم في الشمال والجنوب بينما يقول
الطرف الروسي انه مازال يسيطر على معظم
المناطق التي سيطر عليها مؤخرا في بخموت
هذا الزخم الذي يحاول ان يوحي به الطرف
الاوكراني الى اي مدى هو حقيقي والى اي
مدى وقادر فعليا على قلب الموازين هناك
قبل
وخرسون كانت
روسيه تسيطر على 20% واكثر من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه اليوم بين 15% وال 17% اليوم
هناك عمليه خداع طويله لاول مره ال سي
دوله او جيش يريد ان يهاجم في مكان ويعلن
خطته على العلن ويقول
اليوم لا يمكن قياس هذا النجاح لانه القصف
لا ينهي حرب الاحتلال والعسكر على الارض
هو الذي يهني الحرب اليوم تسعه الويه
اوكرانيه مع 1500 مدرعه 230 دبابه اصبحت
جاهزه يبقى اليوم موضوع الطقس هو العامل
الاساسي اشكرك جزيل الشكر العميد الياس
حنا الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي ضيفنا
هنا في الاستوديو